. You have fascinating new reporting about
mark meadows, Donald Trump's former chief
of staff, also one of the founding members
of the house freedom caucus, still in touch
advising a number of conservatives.
Just a reminder for anyone who might forget,
this is is mark meadows on Newsmax Monday
night.
>> You run out of other people's money.
We are at that point.
They may have made progress today at the white
house with speaker Mccarthy and Joe Biden.
I'm telling you, I think Doug will agree,
that's happy talk.
They are not making progress because they
want to spend your money.
>> Explain why this matters.
Hooegs talking to conservatives who keep telling
Mccarthy, don't up much or we won't back you.
>> Anyone who covers mark meadows knows this
is very on brand.
[12:33:20 PM]
brand.
He spent years trying to undermine leadership,
including Kevin Mccarthy.
We have found that over the last year, even
though he's from the public spotlight, he's
very much working behind the scenes to try
to wheeled influence in Washington.
Especially now that Republicans have control
of the house.
The speaker's race, he was advising the freedom
caucus about what specific demands to make,
gaming out how Mccarthy would use their leverage.
Now he's doing the same thing with the debt
ceiling.
It matters for a couple reasons.
It could impact how these negotiations play
out when you have the hard right trying to
influence and excerpt their leverage, but
it's interesting because mark meadows is arguably
one of the most important witnesses when it
comes to January 6 and the efforts to overturn
the 2020 election.
There are signs the special investigation
is concluding.
So there's a lot of speculation about whether
mark meadows is cooperating.
The legal team is in the dark about whether
or not he is
[12:34:21 PM]
about whether or not he is cooperating, which
anowed them.
It's interesting to see him trying to politically
stay relevant while also maneuvering with
these legal investigations.
>> Such amazing reporting, particularly for
those of us who offered mark meadows, the
freedom caucus chair, not mark meadows, the
white house chief of staff.
That was the guy who made John Boehner's life
a living hell.
Such a different message when he was the chief
of staff because Donald Trump was not afraid
to spend a lot of money.
Like a lot of it.
So I think you're right to be looking at and
questioning whether or not his separation
from Donald Trump on the fiscal matters might
be an indicator about whether he's separating
on legal matters.
>> If meadows has an audience, whether it's
five or 10 or 20 or 40, members saying here's
where you should hold the line.
The white house has to cut.
[12:35:22 PM]
They put a freeze on the table and thought
if we do a freeze, maybe we give a little
bit of the work.
The question is can.com county cut it or what
happens if he doesn't.
This is Ralph Norman.
We asked would he mind if we put his name
up.
The best use is what he does now.
He can offer advice.
It's just a reminder that, again, at any moment,
one person can challenge Kevin Mccarthy.
If he cuts a deal with Biden and to pass the
bill, Kevin Mccarthy could say, wow, I avoid
a default and within 48 hours could have a
speakership challenge.
>> I think that's the ramifications.
We talk a lot about the people and the players.
People at home don't necessarily know if mark
meadows walked past him, they might not know
who he is.
But we have these individuals, these very
small number of individuals are really the
ones kind of holding up this debt ceiling
discussion, but my
[12:36:23 PM]
ceiling discussion, but my question is what
is the end game.
We have people at home worried a about their
social security checks, they are worried about
what this will mean to their own finances
there's no clear end game.
We know mark med does is seizing power and
advising members, but what do they actually
want?
>> I think that's a great question in the
context of what the president wants.
Very different from what a house